e
herkese Merhaba ben Zeynep pişman aile
ve çocuk yazarıyım aynı zamanda
ebeveynleri bilinçlendirmek aileyi
güçlendirme kedisiyle e organizasyonlar
yapıyorum eğitimsel ilerler düzenliyorum
Aslında benim işim yetişkinlerle ancak
Elbette sıklıkla çocuklarla ve gençlerle
bir araya gelebilme çok önemsiyorum
Onları dinlemek onları
gözlemlemek ve baya onları anlamaya
çalışmak benim için çok kıymetli O
yüzden de bugün burada olduğum için ve
bu fırsat bana tanındığı için gerçekten
çok mutluyum ve çok heyecanlıyım Umarım
ilk fırsatta bu Buluşmaları bu
konuşmaları yüz yüze Gözlerinize bakarak
o enerji hissederek de yapabilirim
karşılıklı bir sohbet şeklinde
gerçekleştirebiliriz umarım Bu
neden önemli gençlerle birarada olmak
Çünkü gerçekten bir toplumda değişim
gençlerle başlıyor ama elbette ki
gençlerin bu değişimi yaratabilme leri
için onları gören onları anlayabilen ve
onları destekleyen aileleri ve büyüklere
ihtiyacı var Dolayısıyla bu böyle karşı
cephelerde savaşan Düşmanlar gibi değil
aslında kol kola girdiğiniz ve
yetişkinlerin toplumdaki söz sahibi
insanların ve gençlerin kol kola girdiği
ve Tıpkı aynı takımın oyuncuları gibi
birlikte hareket etmesi gereken bir
süreç işte toplumumuzdaki değişim Bu
sayede başlayacak değişimi ve dönüşümü
Bu sayede görebileceğiz
Ben şimdi bugünkü konuşmamın başlığına
büyük değişim çok küçük adımlarla başlar
dedim neden bu aslında bir motivasyon
konuşması olmayacak
Şöyle düşündüm oldukça zor bir çağın
içinden geçiyoruz
son iki yılımızda pandeli ile birlikte
daha da zorlayıcı ydı iklim krizi
kapımızı çaldı bekliyor dünyadaki
savaşlar malum ülkemizde bir ekonomik
kriz var
salgınlar keza beraberinde pek çok
problemim hem fiziksel hem ekonomik hem
duygusal pek çok problemi beraberinde
getirdi eğitim sistemindeki kaygan zemin
sürekli yaşanan değişikliklerden
kaynaklı Geleceğe dair bir güvensizlik
hissi
hepinizin içinde var Dolayısıyla bu
manzaraya baktığımız zaman Evet çok da
parlak görünüyor gençlerin çoğu ne yazık
ki
umutsuz ve her yerde bir o kadar kaygılı
bu fakat manzara böyle ise
hissettiklerimiz böyle ise ne yapacağız
biz pes edip oturup birşeylerin
değişmesini bekleyip sürekli şikayet mi
gideceğiz yoksa
bize sunulan ları kabul edip sürekli
şikayetleri geçireceğiz ömrünüzü yoksa
Hayır ben bir şey yapamam değil benim de
eski alanım çok kuvvetli bir birey
olarak bir genç olarak bak ne
yapabilirim kendi hikayemi nasıl
yazabilirim ve kendi hikayemde insanlara
nasıl ilham olurum Buna mı odaklanacağız
İşte bu bakış açısı tamamen bizim
sorumluluğumuzda bizim etki alanımız da
şimdi bu son iki yıl özellikle pandemi
Bence tüm insanlığa en çok şunu öğretti
en zor koşullara ile nasıl da dayanma
kapasitemiz olduğunu bu yıl da güçlü
varlıklar olduğumuzu gösterdi aslında
yani ben bu durumun içinden imkansız
çıkamam deyip çok umutsuzluğa kapıldığı
mız çok kötü mü hissettiğimiz anlarda
Dahil düşsek de nasıl ayağa kalktı ımızı
Evet yaralandık evet çok zorlandık
herkesin hikayesi pahalıydı ama bir
şekilde yola devam edebildik ve bugün
buradayız işte bunu görmemizi sağladı bu
gücü görmemizi sağladı ve bu devrin en
büyük özelliği Aslında bu esnek
dayanıklılık yani bilişsel ve duygusal
olarak ne kadar ekleyebilme kapasitemiz
de kapasitesine sahip olduğumuzu alakalı
Çünkü belirsizlikler ve kol çağındayız
Geleceğe dair sadece tahminler
üretebiliyoruz Bu belirsizliklere karşı
dayanıklı olabilen
istikrarla hedefine ulaşmaya çabalayan
üç kere düşse de beş kere kalkabilen
insanlar var o da biliyor günümüzde
Dolayısıyla bu esnekliği geliştirmek
temelden başlayan aileden başlayan bir
şey çok kıymetli diye düşünüyorum
bazı notlar aldım İzninizle onlara da
bakmak istiyorum şimdi
hayatta Elbette ki Her zaman pozitif ve
bizi destekleyen insanlarla bir arada
olması lazım özellikle işte yapma
atıldıktan sonra çokça yolumuza taş
koymaya çalışan bize eleştiren ve bizi
kıyaslayan ya da görmezden gelen
insanlar olacak Fakat işte bunlara nasıl
baktığımız ve burada takılacağız tavır
bence çok kilit nokta
kültürümüz çok tüketim odaklı acımasız
bir kültür ve ve hep başarılı ve mutlu
insan olmak çabasında herkes hep sonuca
bakıyor yani başarılı mı başarısız mı
mutlu mutsuz mu Oysaki kimse ve O sonuca
giden süreçli bir yolculukla
ilgilenmiyor Aslında kıymetli olan işte
o yolculukta neler olduğu yani o
yolculukta kaç kere düştüğümüz o
yolculukta kaç kere başarısız olduğumuz
kaç kere başarılı olduğumuz ya da kaç
kere mutsuz olduğumuz tüm bu deneyimler
Tüm bu zorlanmalar bizi güçlendiriyor
bizi biz yapıyor aslında
[Müzik]
büyük hikayeleri alkışlamak
günümüzün modası adeta Çünkü çok görsel
bir kültürün içindeyiz teknoloji ve
sosyal medya etrafımızı sarmış durumda
ve gerçekten o renkli dünyalar Aslında
günün sonunda
bizleri demoralize ediyor Herkes mi bu
kadar mutlu herkes mi bu kadar başarılı
bir tek ben mi bu kadar yeter sizin
hissine kapımıza neden oluyor Oysa ki
etrafta bunca motivasyon kırıcı şey
varken ben
oy verebileceği küçücük şeyleri
görebilen küçücük adımlarla başlayıp
İlmek ilmek Geleceğini öğren insanların
yaşadıkları süreç çok daha büyük bir
başarı simgesi Aslında ne yazık ki bu
acımasız kültürün içinde İşte bunlar yok
olup gidiyor Yani büyük başarıları
alkışlamak için en kolayı ama toplumda
Bu anlamda sayısız başarıya sahip olmuş
bir sürü insan var bunların hikayelerini
görmek nedir bu hikayeyi görebilmek
engelledi diye düşünüyorum
Dediğim gibi başarı odaklı mutluluk
odaklı kültürde en iyisini yapmaya
çalışmayı beklersek bu Muhtemelen hiçbir
şey yapamayız Yani şunu da en iyi
olacağım Bunu da evi hiç Söylenmemiş
söyleyeceğim hiç yazılmamış yazacağım
Hiç yapılmamış yapacağım gibi bir de
kaygıya girersek bu sene la bir adım
bile ilerlememiz çok zor bir çocuk
kitabından çok sevdiğim değil alıntıyı
paylaşmak istiyorum Sizlerle diyor ki
büyük şeyleri kontrol edemediğini
hissettiğinde burnunun dibindeki
sevdiğin şeylere odakla işte Aslında
bugün yapmak istediğim konuşmanın Özü de
bu cümlede yatıyor
Ben ne yapabilirim ki Ben neyi
değiştirebilirim ki Demek gerçekten
anlamsız Çünkü bir kişinin bile etki
alanı çok kuvvetli Birbirinizin bile
yaptığı şey çok fazla değişimi
yaratabilir en küçük adımda bir adımdır
ve İşte o büyük değişimler küçük
adımlarla başlar Siz küçük bir adım atıp
günün sonunda bir şeylerin değişmeye
başladığını gördüğünüzde daha büyük
adımları atmaya cesaret duyarsınız
Ben bugün sadece
Örneğin bir plastik kullanımına dair bir
farkındalığımızı ve küçücük bir davranış
değişikliği miz ver ki Bir yılın sonunda
doğaya bırakılan kilolarca plastiğin
azalmasına sebep olur sizin bir davranış
değişikliğiniz etrafınızdaki etki
alanındaki onlarca insanın da o
davranışı değiştirmesine ve yıllık
Tüketimin ciddi oranda azalmasına sebep
olur ya da da günlük her gün bir dostumu
Arayacağım Her gün bir dostumun halini
hatırını soracağım diye küçücük bir
karar ve bunu istikrarlı bir şekilde her
gün yapmanız onlarca insanın hayatında
pek çok şeyi değiştirebilir işte
olaylara böyle bir bakış açısından
baktığımız zaman Aslında etki alanımızın
sandığımızdan ne kadar da geniş olduğunu
ve
sabırla sebatkarlık lan kararlılıkla ve
bu ve odaklanarak Ve tabii ki
olabildiğince pozitif bir bakış açısıyla
Memeleri değiştirebileceğiniz de
görebiliriz
lütfen yapamayacakları değil
yapabileceklerinizi odaklanın etki
alanınız da olan şeylere bakın Hatta
belki şimdi bu akşam kağıdı kalemi
elinize alın ve bir liste yapın ben ne
istiyorum diye sorun kendinize ve bunu
gerçekleştirmek için neler yapabilirim
Hemen şimdi Yarın sabah küçücük bir adım
da olsa neler yapabilirim diye kendinize
bir liste yapın bakalım bu liste ne
kadar geniş bir liste olacak ve sonra
adım atın sonra bir adım daha yine çok
sevdiğim bir sözle bitirmek istiyorum
binlerce kilometrelik yolculuk tek bir
adımla başlar bunu lütfen aklınızdan
çıkarmayın harika bir yolculuk olmasını
diliyorum hepimiz için Hoşçakalın
sevgiler
abone ol